- [Voiceover] Gus plans
to install a handrail
around a skating rink.
The rink forms a 40 meter
by 20 meter rectangle.
How many meters of handrail does Gus need?
So here's what we know
about the skating rink.
It's a 40 meter by 20 meter rectangle.
So let's draw the skating rink.
That might help us to visualize,
and we know that one
side length is 40 meters
and another side length is 20 meters.
So Gus definitely needs to put
some handrails 40 meters here
and 20 meters here,
but that is not enough.
As somebody who doesn't know how to skate,
I very much hope Gus puts
handrail on this length
and this length also.
He needs to put the handrails
all the way around the outside
where what we could call
the perimeter of the shape,
the entire distance around the outside.
Because the skating rink is a rectangle,
we know that opposite sides are equal.
So if this length is 40 meters up here,
then this length down here
must also be 40 meters.
And we can do the same thing with 20.
If we have 20 over here,
then the length across
must also be 20 meters.
So now we can figure out the entire amount
of handrail Gus needs, the
amount of meters he needs to buy
to put around the skating rink.
For this first side here,
he needs 40 meters plus
to go down this side,
he'll need another 20 meters of handrail.
Going across the bottom of the rink,
he'll need another 40 meters of handrail,
and then, going up the side,
he'll need another 20 meters of handrail.
So we can add these to find
the total amount he needs.
40 plus 20 is 60.
Then 60 plus 40 plus 40 is 100,
and 100 plus 20 more is 120 meters.
So to go the entire
distance around the outside
of the skating rink, or the
perimeter of the skating rink
with handrail, Gus will
need 120 meters of handrail.